well biden's approval rating on covet
absolutely tanking dropping nearly 20
points in 10 months nearly half of
voters now disapprove of his response
and this poll taken before omicron began
its full-blown rampage mark thiessen
washington post columnist and former
white house speechwriter joins us now
mark uh good morning to you he ran on
kovad he won on kovud now you see his
polls are tanking and there appears to
be no solution your thoughts
yeah and his first act as president was
to pass 1.9 trillion trillion with a t
in in in covet relief and here we are 10
months later and we don't have tests and
we don't and you know there are lines
around the block for pcr tests you can't
get the at-home test and we don't have
uh treatments uh where was the operation
warp speed for treatments why do we not
have all a surplus of all of these uh
all of these different treatments of
course his poll numbers uh on that are
gonna decline but his poll numbers are
underwater on every single topic this is
no president in my lifetime probably in
american history has fallen from grace
so far so fast as joe biden he started
out with 56 approval rating 20 20 points
above water on approval over disapproval
today he's 10 points underwater that is
a 30 point slide in one year no other
president has fallen that far that fast
yeah i mean and the whole response has
as the new york post pointed out has
just been abysmal they write quoting
here the public health response to covet
has been awful ever since cases first
appeared in wuhan the reaction has been
marked by mistakes reversals outright
lying and even political manipulation
it's time for a rigorous investigation
perhaps a truth and reconciliation
commission with subpoena power to get to
the bottom of how our public health
authorities have mismanaged this
pandemic mark you think back i mean they
were shutting down beaches and parks and
outdoor space and putting people inside
it was lethal and it was excused
yeah no it's i mean we had after the 9
11 attacks we had the 911 commission uh
which went back and did a lessons
learned exercise not so much to lay
blame but just to figure out how did we
mess up so badly how do we miss this
attack and how can we make sure that we
don't do it again well we need the same
thing when it comes to when it comes to
the coveted response there have been so
many mistakes as you indicated uh and
just go but just look at the cdc they
they
they banned testing from private labs
from doing testing and the crucial folks
released the pandemic and then they
contaminated their own tests uh they
came up with this six foot distancing uh
protocol that wasn't based on any
science at all and ended that was what
caused all the school shut down so there
have been so many mistakes not just by
presidents but by the public health
bureaucracy and we need to figure out
just as we held the intelligence
community into account we need to hold
the public health bureaucracy to account
for why they made so many mistakes and
how we can avoid them in the future
yeah i mean you know now you talk about
look the cdc says don't get on a cruise
ship do not get on a cruise ship yeah
but you can go in the casino with 3 000
others and sit there and for 10 hours
and play craps uh your best and worst
mark i want to think about joe biden
among the 10 best you say some of them
according to you standing up for taiwan
signing the 1.2 trillion infrastructure
plan accelerating vaccine delivery at
home and abroad sidelining the court
packing movement on the left and among
mark thiessen's worst the afghanistan
withdrawal debacle weaponizing the fbi
of course to go after parents in the
critical race theory debate unleash
unleashing the worst border crisis in
u.s history pushing vaccine mandates and
failing to deliver on promises if it was
christmas the naughty list is way above
the nice list for mark thiessen
it is very much so i started doing this
in the washington post during the trump
administration every year i did the 10
best and 10 worst things the president
did and uh you know just like uh blind
squirrel finds an acorn joe biden did
some good things as president in his
first uh first year i came up with 10 of
them uh and they're there in my
washington post column but winnowing
down the the worst list to just 10 was
really one of the hardest journalistic
challenges i've ever faced
yeah mark thiessen happy new year sir
thank you for coming on
thank you take care hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now